look at that
yeah it's a that's a fact yep so we uh
we got the story from insider birth
control pills that add three million
doses of hormones to our waste water
every day some of that estrogen may wind
up in our taps
yeah this is a story i heard about a
while back hormones from birth control
pills can travel through showers toilets
and washing machines to local wastewater
facilities
in his book troubled water activist seth
siegel writes that birth control pills
add more than 10 million doses of
synthetic estrogen to u.s wastewater
every day from there the hormones could
get discharged into rivers and lakes
that serve as sources of drinking water
only only a tiny portion of the estrogen
and wastewater makes its way to u.s taps
but siegel still thinks we should remove
it so i think maybe it's a bit
exaggerated as if you're like turning
the tap water on and there's gonna be
birth control in it it looks like it
could be an issue we all also aren't we
having a fertility crisis
what is that all about like there's we
just aren't having enough kids does it
mean that people aren't trying enough or
that it's people there's a lot of trying
and there's a lot of not having children
like because they're light too light
what there's that there's like being
older
um and then there's uh
being older is one of the things but
there's also been issues of fertility
like there's i don't have enough
information food supply high fructose
corn syrup aspartame we have birth
control you have how many uh oxycodone
how many of these pharmaceuticals that
are legal are getting pissed into the
water supply that's kind of crazy what
are your guys's thoughts on birth
control
i have lots of thoughts on birth control
you would hear him yes
so i went on birth control when i was 16
my doctor said that i had polycystic
ovarian syndrome and that
i should go on birth control to regulate
my cycle
so i did i did go on birth control um
and then i was on it for a very long
time i was on it until i was 32
32 33
something like that and then i went off
it because i wanted to have a child and
i had for that whole period of time i
thought i was depressed i thought i was
maladjusted
i thought it was awkward i thought i
like was socially weird i thought all of
these things about myself that i was
like morose miserable and then i went
off birth control and it literally felt
like a dam broke
in my entire body and in my brain also
where it was like suddenly i could see
everything in color
and
i just felt like an entirely
different person
and i suddenly really was more outgoing
i liked being around people more i
wasn't really depressed i mean i was
still miserable because i'm still me but
i wasn't like depressed about everything
um it was shocking it was so shocking
that i had to go back on it within a
month and i had to like wait a little
bit to go off
yeah wow well there's there's and then
it turned out that i didn't have
polycystic ovarian syndrome i wasn't
infertile there was no reason for me to
be on the pill that entire time and i
had suffered from like for a while i was
on this pill where if i went into the
sun i would pass out
right and i was in la i was like this is
not working there's there's two i do not
recommend birth control there's two big
issues one is the feminist view that
birth control has empowered women
because now they're free to function you
know without fear of pregnancy which
could potentially hold them back or
whatever but then there's also the fact
that our society has mass medicated
young women that's correct and i'm
wondering have we tracked for the
psychological impacts of mass medicating
young women well i've gone through like
i've done a little study of
other you know essentially upper middle
class girls um
in my age group
all of us were put on birth control when
we were about 16. like every one of us
and i was like did you have a reason
well my doctor said my periods were
weird and the reason that they say stuff
they give you a reason is so that your
insurance covers it right
so my insurance covered it for the
entire time the doctor
wanted you on it or yeah the doctors
want 16 year old upper middle class
girls in the u.s on birth control so
that they don't have teen pregnancies
i mean
i guess teen pregnancy is a bad thing
but like
you know that's yes it's it it
now i sound crazy but in looking at like
all of the women i know of that age it's
very like this keeps this has happened
to all of us birth control makes it
harder to have kids and they're peeing
it into the water supply and it's harder
for people to have kids
when they give mice a lovely place to
live and enough bedding and enough food
and enough everything and eventually the
mice go a bit crazy and
turn on each other and stop having sex
and oh that's like america
well
you just wonder
we do talk about the the utopia
experiment quite a bit i think he did it
the guy did it with mice and rats like
he did one in the other and um
a finite amount of space but unlimited
food and water and then the red just see
what they do and they would have what's
called behavioral sync where they their
their
rat society would break down and they
would start eating each other and
killing each other i was thinking about
that because we're effectively running a
chicken utopia experiment and i'm half
kidding but we launched a youtube show
called chicken city which is just live
showing the chickens where they have a
large amount of space
unlimited food and water
and
like we have no intention of like
harvesting the chickens i'm wondering if
we'll see something break down or if
chickens will just you know not be like
they're different you know different
species i wonder if it's different from
you know mammals do they have a limited
space
they do yeah it's big though
but uh uh the the rats in the mice had
limited space but it was a decent amount
what was interesting is that in those
experiments they would all cluster in
one bunch in one area and not utilize
the full space they were given
so i just wonder if we lack purpose
you know i i just look at you know if my
kids ever talk about millionaires
uh sort of kardashian-style millionaires
and i'm like they're billionaires
they're billionaires well billionaires
millionaires billionaires just a lot
more than me but i sort of look at them
and i think what's the purpose of their
day
like what are they striving for and do
we as human beings need something to
strive for because if you've got nothing
to to aim for to go for to move forward
for
then don't you just stay still and then
just become unhappy yes
so i had a friend who became a
millionaire when he was like 16.
and he said that he had an existential
crisis right because all of a sudden
it's not just the fact that he was rich
and could buy anything he wanted it was
that all of a sudden he was like the
lord of everyone the way people treated
him he no longer had uh like teachers
who would tell him he was wrong all of a
sudden it was like hey let me get that
for you oh you're so smart wow look what
you've done and he said that you know it
happens to all of these guys in tech who
become millionaires rather quickly
because they like write a code write a
program then overnight it sells and now
they're worth three million bucks and
they're sitting at this massive bank
account thinking what do i do now like
you wrote the code you wrote the program
you solved the problem and now you're
rich
but they never they never did this work
because they were trying to get money
they were trying to accomplish something
and they become listless depressed they
sleep all day he told me that eventually
most of them will go like six months to
a year then finally
normalize and then you know their happy
happiness stabilizes and they try and
find their next mission or whatever but
i think that that you know hearing that
story
and then think about the fact that i
think
most people in the united states today
are living like kings
may be why we're dealing with this
collapse this behavioral sync i i
definitely think the us is dealing with
behavioral sync like much like the right
utopia
i think
you know you've got i've seen it with
like occupy wall street
all of these people protesting this is
you know now almost 11 years ago or 10
years ago
when i went to when i was in brazil and
many who listened to this show probably
heard me tell the story but forgive me
because i haven't told it to kelly
when i went to brazil
i was in the favelas and i met you know
the favelas are shantytowns they're they
fall apart in the rain
and uh some one of the the woman asked
me in portuguese a question and it was
translated why are the rich people
protesting in the united states
and i said
it's a very good question but i said i
don't understand they're not and then
she asked and he was like oh she's she's
asking about like occupy wall street
and i was like oh those were like
college kids kids with debt city people
living in cities and she left just like
the americans are all rich
her question was like i think it was
probably mistranslated she wasn't saying
why are specifically the american rich
people protesting she was saying
something like why would americans who
are rich protest about this stuff and
it's really interesting because i'm like
hey you're preaching to the choir man i
i'm like if you got air conditioning in
a refrigerator you're living better than
rockefeller did 100 years ago so we're
all basically taken care of what do we
do with our lives
create problems you know complain about
stuff i sometimes think you get to the
top of maslow's hierarchy of needs and
then it inverts yeah and then we're just
heading for just doomed so kim
kardashian came under a lot of fire that
i didn't think she deserved because
recently she said something along the
lines of you need to work hard and
everyone's like oh you're rich you don't
know what it's like but she keeps
herself busy didn't she go to law school
like she didn't just like she didn't go
to law school but she has been reading
law right doing this other different way
to get a law degree she has a company
right and she's doing all this different
stuff i completely agree like you should
be staying busy no matter how much money
you make and especially if you get
richer it's like the matrix you know and
in the first matrix agent smith tells
morpheus he's like the first world we
designed was perfect but the human mind
rejected it because it craves conflict
and struggle
it's like yeah without it people become
almost deranged
well also we we have a lack of so i'm
what you call a gold star atheist i've
never believed in god
um but i think the organized religion
and the
mutual purpose of people and collective
purpose
of heading towards an afterlife of
actually trying to do good
uh for something that you can never
touch
i think that also has has left us
wanting and i think the where we've
looked is within our narcissistic little
bodies yeah that's right we have turned
in and we we worship the self where we
used to worship god and now we do we do
worship the self and we have uh removed
the soul we've extricated the soul and
replaced it with gender
ah so beautiful
i do think it's interesting that the
culture war has made a lot of people
like theist
or whatever i've got a theology degree
so i'm a
vested interest in you're an atheist
with a theology degree
yeah i mean i love this that sounds
right i want to hear everything a
theologist yeah tell me about it a
theologist
that's wonderful no
i think that makes sense if you're going
to be an atheist to know what you're
talking about well i thought i'd find
some so for a start i thought university
because
i'm an idiot was going to be like kids
from fame which is probably way too old
a reference from any of you i liked um i
liked the show so you just sit in an
individual chair and you'd all sort of
discuss these really meaty topics it
wasn't quite like that but
i i just thought there may be universal
truths
and if i study theology i may find
universal truths and then i may examine
my own belief system but that didn't
actually happen
however i do think the universal truth
of human beings absolutely needing
something above and beyond themselves
is something that now we're finding out
to our peril
yeah do you think above and beyond like
a partner
i think anything that that makes you put
yourself a little bit lost
um whether that be family community
that's you know whilst we've lost our
organized religions uh in the uk
probably more than in the us
but and it's no mistake that in poor
countries they still are very religious
so whilst we've lost our religions we've
also lost our sort of touch touch your
parents because they're just next door
kind of culture we don't have
communities
we've all moved away from each other
many people live tens of miles if not
hundreds or thousands of miles away from
their parents
and i just don't i just think these real
things that you can reach out and touch
are things that we desperately need
doesn't it doesn't it feel almost like
it's intentional i mean think about it
the idea that you turn 18 move out move
away from your parents separate from
your family go off to college you go to
college what happens you get a bunch of
strangers indoctrinating these
institutionalized learning facilities it
just seems like a lot of things that
have happened over the past 60 70 years
have effectively orchestrated the
downfall of the family and our society
i'm not saying that's really interesting
i'm saying it's just like you've got
people who heavily advocate for
separating yourself from your community
from your family i just think that's
interesting when i when i was looking at
college and stuff my mom wanted me to go
to college very far away we lived in
philadelphia
i had only lived with my mom for two
years i didn't know her that well i
didn't really grow up with her um and
she was like you should go to california
you should go somewhere far away for
college and i was like
i'll go to new york like you know but
i'm not how far do you really want me to
go like i still i barely know you i
don't have a home anywhere you know i
was totally rootless
and so i landed in new york and it's
still a situation where i have i feel
like i have no roots anywhere i feel
like i have like
when i look around you guys know i've
had this struggle should i stay should i
go in new york and it's like i don't
know where i'd go
if there was a place where i could go
home if it was like oh i could just go
back home i would do that but i don't
have
i don't have any like
place that is the home that i know
other than new york city it's weird i
had that growing up we would go my dad's
mom my grandma we lived like eight
blocks away so we would go there every
four days a week three days a week two
days a week whatever awesome and then i
moved in college i left the state and i
now i haven't seen my parents i see them
once every two years or something it
doesn't feel right i was just talking to
my mom yesterday about that just
it's only six hour drive but like it
doesn't have that feeling of we're gonna
pop over to my grandma's house on the
weekend thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there